hello and welcome to the agenda
the hunt for the new european ombudsman
heats up on tuesday and the six
candidates vying for the job put their
best foot forward and a special hearing
of parliament's petition committee
each of the six candidates has 55
minutes to convince members of the
committee that they're the right person
to defend all of us in times of
institutional abuse two of the
candidates already serve as national
ombudsmen in their native countries
could that give them the edge
nico for us dear honduras's successor
will be decided by meps in a secret
ballot at the plenary in july so giving
a good interview on tuesday will be
crucial
last week the french president francois
hollande declared that the euro crisis
was over and called for a push for
growth
the commission has come under attack for
its unrelenting fiscal consolidation on
monday commissioners olly run and laszlo
andor take the floor to discuss their
recommendations for each country for the
next cycle of the european semester at a
joint sitting on the economic and
employment committees the commission has
already said that they will give member
states more time to correct their
deficits
i couldn't have done this a week ago the
weather's been miserable an effect of
global warming fluorinated gases account
for two percent of europe's greenhouse
gases they can be found in refrigerators
air conditioning and air assaults the us
and china last week joined forces to
tackle harmful gases and now in a new
measure to combat global warming the
environment committee will vote on a
proposal to cut fluorinated greenhouse
gases on wednesday afternoon and a quick
mention of the 25th acp eu parliamentary
assembly that's taking place from monday
till wednesday
the conference involves afro-caribbean
and pacific countries and will give meps
the chance to discuss a wide range of
issues including human rights abuse and
the protection of journalists not one to
miss
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week